today on our show man the man who walks
between world that's right we got a
guest and he's [ __ ] special stick
around for the brand-new fat man on
Batman Oh what's up man hold welcome
back mark barnard chuckles here is Mark
Martin and we're gonna dive into a show
here today man this the origins of this
show ladies and gentlemen very Hollywood
I was getting a pedicure the other day
as one goes well [ __ ] y'all because he
was getting a pedicure as well I was
getting paid my wife is like I'm gonna
get pedicure I said I [ __ ] I'll go get
pedicure with you I want to get pedicure
I don't do the manicured oh really no
man manicure you bite your teeth but I
can't bite my toenails because I can't
[ __ ] can't reach if I can reach that
low I'd be blind a lot more of my
toenails I mister might be the first
time I've ever said that might be too
much you know I'm getting my toes done
and there's a kind of cross we get miss
toes done he said hi and I looked up and
immediately I was like oh it's you like
the way they used to show in movies
where there'd be a POV shot and then
come up on a person and be like it's you
and then that person be shot or
something like that I was very much like
a musical sequence very much this
neither of those things happen because
we were the [ __ ] getting our feet
scraped but what started was a great
conversation man because I was like this
[ __ ] walked just between two
worlds man you're you're gonna recognize
them instantly the moment we put him on
camera grin that [ __ ] guy but what's
amazing about this show is you're gonna
learn that guy's [ __ ] name more than
that 10 minutes I talked to this dude
while I was getting my feet done 15 I'll
eat my hat in that time this dude gave
better guests than like almost [ __ ]
90% of people I've ever spoken to well
on our other podcasts he was a living
anecdote generator dude and like every
store I was like ooh it's adorable
that's amazing and there's all
relevant to our world okay so it's a big
buildup so what we're gonna do is tell
you to dude it's [ __ ] bona fides then
we're gonna tell you his name then we're
gonna [ __ ] give you a single this
[ __ ] and when he [ __ ]
dramatically looks at you you're gonna
be like I know exactly who that is man
yes in fact before we [ __ ] even
announce who he is this is very the lead
right let's show the face oh and then
we'll [ __ ] tell everybody your give
him a single ready oh come on you know
who that is on a swivel come back to uh
for the wide show right here not just
the truth yeah yeah the guy from the
Wendy's commercials this is now here we
got to do it cuz it's tough this is Dave
just a small chin Dave's last name is
spelling for him DASD mal ch IA n took
me till I was in kindergarten till I
could spell it had to learn how the
alphabet but by the time I was on a I
was on a show one time in a production
office I went to pick up her diem and
they said we figured out how to say your
name
this small chin so ever since then I
tell people you're from the Bronx you
got hit on too small chin this mulching
what does that nationality by it's a
it's a it's an Iranian name it's Farsi
and it's it means a seller of
handkerchief really where you you are
descended from a bunch of people like
Crescent circle people had a cold you
went to my ancestors and you picked up
there's only one guy you can go to I
gotta go to the channel [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's amazing
Dave here as you look at him you're like
why do I [ __ ] know that guy you're
not even saying that cuz right away look
I know that guy some face you give him a
single some faces you see him you'll
never [ __ ] it forget man you ain't gonna
forget that face for two reasons I'll
tell you why go back to the watch shot
you saw a little picture called the Dark
Knight remember that he was in it dude
you saw a little picture and when I say
little I'm not just making puns called
ant-man he was in it man look Ari
there's the look right there from
[ __ ] dargah you remember that was
dude in the chair that dark nut was like
he's a disease by defense
[ __ ] and Harvey take him out and you
have a scene with ya know you guys it's
awesome to be here thank you guys for
having me it's amazing
first of all I'm glad you went now I'm
not giving away my secret location now
though dude that's not what got him on
the show got him on the show is the
moment he started talking I was like oh
my god you're [ __ ] podcasters wet
dream well everything was a wonderful
well rounded anecdote let's take him to
the beginning yes because those are two
massive run as I said that's a man who
walks between two worlds he's got a foot
in DC and he got a foot in marvel as
well big foot in [ __ ] Marvel so this
is a guy who's done wrong it was done a
lot more since then
it's been it's it is for anybody who you
know watches it's just it's it is a
dream it's the biggest dream if it's
insane I was uh you know I grew up in
Kansas I started buying comics and I a
when I was nine years old
the first calm third grade it was an
Avenger I actually brought it well
that's a part of a story I get to but
you can actually see the trace marks
because I used to want to illustrate and
so you can I used to trace and this is
such a great cover because it's got all
you know so many of the heroes right yes
but I was that same summer I was known
as gets spinning rack at a 7-eleven in
Kansas City and then and then I soon
found a place called Clint's comic south
which was a comic shop where I started
riding my bike all the time and I
started and then I that was soon after
that when you know Miller's Dark Knight
was
and then death in the family and all
these amazing so I was really in love
with which Joker played such an integral
part of some of those so I was a huge
fan of the villains of DC and then the
heroes of Marvel and I continued I
actually the first this is embarrassing
to admit now as an adult but the first
serious collection that I subscribe to
that I got monthly was the West Coast
Avengers which a lot of you give me [ __ ]
for but I loved those guys and I was 9
man
Tigra was like my first boy-girl
4-stroke inspiration yeah yes and the
Wonder Man was ready appreciate they
don't say [ __ ] but it is how could you
not does that also have Marvel Man in it
as well no wonder man that's Wonder Man
Wonder Man was was was was attitude all
the time and and Clint was the leader of
the gang but Hank got involved and so
and I really was Hank was in a dark
period when they were riding him into
the West Coast off and I thought this
guy's amazing so then I started doing
more research into like who's Hank Pym
and then I started to learn about the
Avengers and then as you get older you
dig further back into the history of the
comics so now as a grown up being in
both of these worlds has been you know
it's it's it's it literally is my wake
up sometimes I still can't believe that
this is that's right dude you'd be a
Hank Pym fan or at least a familiar with
Hank Pym as a West Coast Avengers rear
years later they're like you're gonna be
in a scene with Hank Pym Michael Douglas
dammit
like oh my god take me back to like
Romancing the Stone and being like oh so
yeah I was a I went from Kansas City to
Chicago I was studying theater I became
a theatre actor and I don't I don't know
how long to make this story but I was I
know you know who you met back in the
day you know I'm I'm I'm doing Theatre
in Chicago you're not making any money
and I was a telemarketer by day and I
was working at a movie theater um sweet
and popcorn and I I got a chance to
audition for one of my favorite film
makers in the indie side of things
got in Chris Smith who made American
movie Oh [ __ ] I love American movie
movie the two guys making their horror
film covin so movies who directed that
it was shooting this commercial and it
and we just hit it off immediately and
he really taught me how to get in front
of these things because it was very
different coming from the stage and so
how much theater had you done and where
did you do any Chicago a lot I mean I
was working all over time doing the like
storefront 45 folding chair see theaters
then starting to make my way up into the
bigger regional theater so when I did
the commercial with Chris round that
same time I got to start working in
bigger theaters and I was playing
Montano in a production of Othello and
Amelie is called writers there were the
really cool big theaters in Chicago and
and now I started getting in front of
the camera and feeling comfortable with
it and I wanted to go work in movies I
mean that was my dream that was my goal
I wanted to go so I was gonna save up
enough money to move to Hollywood and go
for it and what about is this this is
2006-2007 right the winner of 2006 2007
I made up my mind I I hear that the
Batman movie they're seeing the sequel
to the Batman Begins it's gonna come
into Chicago and they're gonna cast
they're gonna be looking for people and
I'm like don't they know that I'm the
god like I I know like I could tell them
anything they want to know what DC
villains I'll carry a hook into a scene
and just let me be there please so I'm
doing this this play we started
rehearsals the beginning of April and my
agent called and said you're gonna go in
an audition for one of the bank robbers
and there's this there's a scene we
don't really know much about it but
you're a clown like a masked bank robber
and that the sides they gave me were
dummy sides of course but it was
something like he thinks he's getting my
share of the money have you seen this
guy yeah I was supposed to pick up some
you know something too that way no no
the scene man that's that's me so I
prepared it like crazy man I went in
there John Papp sedara had come into
town from LA to do some casting casting
huge casting agency guys done
everything's done I think yes and he and
he and as I'm sitting in this waiting
room with all the other Chicago actors a
guy walks by
who's John's assistant and is like hey
you're the dude from that commercial the
one that Chris had directed me and we're
it's like a silly cellphone commercial
mmm I was like yeah music oh no is that
a bad thing that they're gonna think I
might say
commercial guy and he's like we loved
that spot come here I want you two to
meet John the casting directors I go in
with Papp cetera
I read the scene he's like I really like
what you're doing you brought something
specific to this character I want you to
meet our director so the next day I'm
only this is a strip mall that you go
into in a shot of me and mark
holy [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
holy [ __ ] sorry the story is not as
interesting but it's still kind of
interesting so that you go to the signs
everywhere say Rory's first kiss that
was like the fake name that they were
yeah so I go in and I remember it's
freezing cold Chicago winter and it's
probably like yeah it's beginning of
April and I and I ain't going with
Christopher Nolan and he's sitting in a
small room he's got a little handheld
camera and I do this scene the the bank
robbery scene and he gave me a little
direction and then we shook hands and
and I walked out and I never feel this
way I was just like it's mine I got it
I'm going to Robert and I got in the car
I called my mom I knew I tried to never
do this I was like mom like yeah what's
it for is like I don't want it I don't
want to tell her what price it's very
important so then I go back to
rehearsals and about a week or so later
I I'm on my way to rehearsal and I open
the paper and there's this article that
they've shot this this Bank I seen at
the old post office in downtown Chicago
and they're describing the guys with the
clown masks on and I'm going oh I was
devastated I mean I was my soul was like
wounded I I was crushed but in your
heart you had that you met the dude when
was a guy like me gonna get an
opportunity to audition for one of the
greatest reboots of one of my favorite
universe I mean I one of the greatest
American living the filmmaker you know I
was just like so I rode the RET I
remember I'll never forget I the rest of
the ride up to to my stop and then and I
allowed myself that time to just be
devastated and then I got off the train
I was like time to go do Shakespeare
[ __ ] sorry guys right so I go to
the show and that's the
you got to approach life it's like you
thought you had it you didn't what he
gonna do he can't kick it screaming like
[ __ ] it moving back moving on to
something that's great I'm getting to do
this awesome show with these amazing
actors for months that job was from
rehearsal to opening we extended all the
way to closing July 21st my birthday hmm
my agent calls and at this point I have
let go I mean I every time I'd see that
they were shooting in Chicago I'd always
go down and stand with everybody else
behind the things and and they and my
agent Cley said well I don't know what
to make of this they're being real real
secretive but they want you to be in the
Batman movie and you're gonna be a thug
and they really won't tell us anything
else but they need to know if you have a
passport and I said I don't and he said
we'll go get one so I just ran to the
post office and I got a passport
expedited and um and I said I went I
told you the story the other day I had
to go to that back that that office the
strip club not strip club strip mall
office and sign like some documents to
get these sides that were like two pages
that were all ex out except for like
everything's redacted everything is like
there he is
let's get him and I'm just it said I was
the driver so I was preparing that
driving around my I think at that point
I traded in the the Chevy's 83 celebrity
for my Dodge Intrepid 96 which was just
making a lot of noise I was trying I
mean I had the character I'd created
this thing and then I went to the
fitting the day before we shot and they
put me in this cop uniform and I said
why am I dressed like a policeman and
Linda hemming the Christopher Nolan's
wardrober suit
Christopher super-secret duty isn't told
you don't know anything and I was like
no I don't know anything sick you'll be
fine and the next day I went to work
down you still don't [ __ ] know well
no idea I think I'm a driver why am I so
I'm coming up with new justifications
like oh maybe we uh maybe I went
undercover and I stole like an armored
vehicle I don't know look at you acting
big the most elaborate episode of Punk'd
20 22 years
I don't know anybody that's like I came
up with an arrow
for my to lunge alive hold this guy
that's smart so I and I didn't think I
was gonna according to this I wasn't
have any lines so I'd already created a
character who couldn't communicate
except through this condition that I had
kind of imagined that was like he had
the ability to giggle like imagine that
that horrifying reality where if no
matter what you were trying to really
say all you could really do was just let
out a little giggle so then I get to
work the next day first day I mean you
guys it was like the Chicago still he's
in Chicago and it was a huge first day
they had the entire parade they were
starting to set up down near LaSalle and
they had thousands of extras dressed
like cops and like you know for the
funeral parade zuman's and the first
thing I actually shot was um being in
the back of the ambulance after I've
been shot and and and and Harvey Dent
comes in and says you know tell me what
you know and I'm not going to it so he
kidnaps me basically and as I'm getting
dressed one of the producers the film he
came you know and he's like so this this
is what we're really doing today and
that's the first moment you hear what's
happened what I actually knew what I was
going to be doing fully in the film and
if you looked at the page it was only
the line was I I didn't even have a line
in that scene it was just supposed to be
but it said I smirk I think was the the
direction I've got my script here
somewhere and it's and I remember
thinking aaron eckhart already is
scaring the [ __ ] out of me he's so it's
so intense he has such charisma I
thought like how how would I ever be
able to smirk or like intimidate him and
make him feel threatened and luckily
that I think this idea of having this
kind of giggle it could be interpreted
as sarcastic when somebody or it could
also be like fearless and in reality
then when I found out that my character
was actually supposed to be mentally ill
it played it couldn't have worked out
better you know dude you played someone
from Arkham you know what I'm saying
you're telling me nuts and to find out
the day of like you get there and you're
like I don't know what I'm doing and
they're like you're gonna play somebody
who goes to Arkham [ __ ] and and
the rest of that week was standing next
to one of the greatest actors of our
time in the and I got to sit in hair and
makeup
morning with with with Heath and with
Christian Bale and with aaron eckhart
and everyone who was in that sequence we
were called the same time and they
shared hair and makeup and Heath Ledger
was playing the music that he was
turning me on to and I just got to stand
around with him for like five days what
was he like amazing really good guy
crossbow I never met him once at a
Spirit Awards ceremony I made a joke
during the ceremony and afterwards he
was with Michelle Williams and they were
standing outside and walked past me was
a guy was funny I was like me gang now
is I think it was the year of Brokeback
I think I made a Brokeback Jim about
spitting in the hand I just that was
funny but I liked him in Brokeback [ __ ]
when they announced him as the Joker you
know there was a lot of people I don't
know if people remember but a lot of
cats were like what the [ __ ] the guy
from 10 Things I Hate About You oh [ __ ]
out Joker but I remember seeing
Brokeback and being like this dude's an
actor like he likes to go places the way
that Oldman likes to go places her Nic
Cage likes to go places I was like I
think we'll be safe and then he [ __ ]
turned in something that made you forget
about Jack Nicholson's Joker which is
one most unforgettable [ __ ] on stage
don't litter tallest [ __ ] order they
did fill the shoes I see I said do it I
say I was a little ballsy when I think
back to how scared I was being on that
set the fact that I made this he he was
one of those human beings that you meet
and they immediately you he just set me
at ease in a great way and as did get
almost everybody around that that set
but he had a he had a very like special
quality about him as just a person that
as soon as you met you were just like it
was something like really I don't want
to describe it and and I I mean we were
two seconds into conversating about
[ __ ] whatever just hey how's it
going and I said um I said you know I
you know I'm a huge fan of this of this
world and when I heard that you know you
were playing this part I thought like
god wow and then I then I stopped my
cells like David what talking the power
and he looked at me and he goes yeah me
too and I said how's it going and we
started laughing and he
I'm having the time of my life and he
was he was having the best time ever and
we just knew that we stood around he was
the kind of person that didn't know me I
was I was basically a glorified extra in
that film and yet he he knew I was going
to travel internationally for the first
time in my life and that I was nervous a
little bit of I was gonna go to London
and stay in a hotel and he said yeah
I've got a flat if you ever want to stay
at my place
in London this is just that kind of
person you know and also there's the
sequence where we're the honor guard
mm-hmm and we are supposed to be
shooting to the whatever the sky why we
turn on the mayor we're gonna we're
gonna shoot the newly appointed mayor
Nestor Carbonell and oldman saves him in
and and and I grew up in Kansas and I
was I grew up with guns but I was very
on this this sequence was really
uncomfortable for me because you don't
see it in the film of course they cut so
much stuff but there was a whole thing
of us with the guns and then and he got
excused at one point to go be relieved
and he saw me over like trying to learn
it and he came over and spent like an
hour with me just showing me tricks he'd
learned over his time in film because he
knew this was my I told him this is my
first film
well he was teaching me how to use a gun
and stuff like that so thoughtful guy he
easily could have been like hey man
we're all on our own here I got [ __ ] to
think about but he was like hey what you
doing man let me help they said well
lead you into the fraternities go to
your trade you want to go to your
trailer arrest and he anyways they go
okay and then he sees this kid over
there trying to look like he knows what
he's doing he just came over and for no
reason you know you mentioned music
before what music was he listening to
interesting I still really dig band
called Animal Collective and he turned
me on to them one morning we're
listening to his actually panda bear
who's in that band had done like a side
project and he was playing this music
and I was like oh that's really cool and
and he had been to this club in Chicago
that I used to go see a bunch of cool
indie bands play and so we started
talking about bands that we liked in
common and yeah certain songs I'll
listen to now and I still remember like
man I wouldn't know this if blood yeah
and that weird Caesarea Heath Ledger
turned me on this band yeah makes me
showoff every time I play it in the car
to whoever's in the car hey everyone
shut up yeah man I how long did you
spend in that we know his father like
almost a total of there was a full week
day week because there is so many angles
of that stuff and there was so much
going on with the downtown and the chaos
and everything so there was there was a
couple days where I didn't actually work
they had me called and I'd be standing
there and we just got to hang out hang
out and watch Batman and we'd be like
this close to the Joker and not see a
seam I mean the makeup was you were that
close in any sense I'm in the only scene
that he has is makeup yeah that's right
where he's just like white skin -
there's not one not white skin peach
skin but yeah and that's one shot words
like these and makeup lists Joker yeah
man
it was it was like I was creeped out by
it in a wonderful way I mean this is my
did you get to go to overseas I did so
then a month after that I went to London
and you guys got to remember at this
point moving in Chicago I mean the top
game I was making in theater I was
probably bringing in $500 a week and I
had this little apartment a studio
apartment I get to London and I go into
the Mandarin Oriental in Hyde Park and
like there's some Sheikh staying on my
floor so that he's got all these crates
of shopping that they've just done I was
like where am I they gave me a burner
phone I called my mom I mean like the
bathroom of the hotel was bigger than my
studio apartment in Chicago and I would
just hang out in there and it like
echoed so that was and I was there on
weather cover because they weather cover
with it for them to do the ambulance
scene no no there's a scene after the
ambulance he takes me to another
location which is where a subway that
was gonna be in
this interior and though and the reason
why they shot that in in in the UK was
because the the director had already
scouted where he wanted the scene to
take place at the end of the film when
Harvey Dent has kidnapped of
Commissioner Gordon's kid kids and so so
that location where they shot it
although it's not the same location in
the film Hugh I think textually and one
of them visually did you know similar
because that's two points at which we
see Harvey Dent really when when he
reveals his darker nature with my
character and and then later it's fully
revealed so so they were shooting
exteriors and they bring when your
weather cover you're brought in in case
the weather gets bad since mine's an
interior shot they'd call me and say
okay we're gonna jump you're Cena 21
days 21 days weather was gorgeous
and they're giving me per diem every day
and I got to go see shows you talked
about Patrick Stewart earlier one of my
huge hero of mine I get to go see him
doing Macbeth I mean just so this is
what movies cost a hundred fifty million
dollars towels were the grand dude like
in order and this was done know why to
save money to bring him over and put him
on weather cover means that like okay if
it rains we could quickly shoot
something else and we'll shoot this sure
but in order to do that they had
unexpectedly the whole October in London
was just gorgeous for three weeks and so
then they called me finally my number
came up and it was time to go and I got
in the UM I got in the car to go to set
oh man I was like I was so scared and
you know at this point about do I know
the scene you know you're like oh my god
then finally like I will give us this is
what's gonna happen next and on the
drive there I had there's just a surreal
life one of the like moments I'll never
I can just I can be right I can be
sitting in the back of that car right
now and I'll never forget and we're
pulling down this long driver in South
London and we're pulling towards this
massive beautiful industrial structure
kind of on the horizon as we're getting
closer and it's coming into focus and I
can see the way that it's lit just
by the moon I was like I I know this
this this building and the driver is
lovely guys like oh yeah that's where
they that's the cover of that you know
that Pink Floyd album animals like
that's the cover of the album and I
thought that is that's exactly it's the
Battersea Power Station which is the
industrial really the cover of people's
which is another huge thing in my life
Pink Floyd so then we get there and and
I went upstairs and they had and they
had turned that the inside of this old
this old power station into the place
where I was going to get interrogated
now had you seen him in the suit prior
to this no first time dudes what does it
look like in a real room so so insane
I'm sitting there and the actor in me
goes well he's gonna save me and I don't
know if I'll be on camera when I doubt I
will cuz usually when you're the like
low guy on that ladder they're gonna
shoot everyone else's coverage and they
get to you last but just in case I want
that moment the first time I see Batman
to be as real as it can possibly be
because I was just shaking literally
shaking and no acting and so they get me
in the chair and they they test
everything and at this point I know that
that he's on set because the presence of
the room has just gotten really serious
and there was like a I don't know why
they had a oh I think it was just a
light bouncer so you know wipeouts it's
something over here but he was on the
other side of it so I knew I wasn't
gonna see him until it was the time and
he was warming up his voice and he was
getting ready and Aaron was pacing and
getting ready for his and we did a like
a wider first time all the way kind of
through and we're doing it and and he
and he he comes you know he's he's in my
periphery at the point that he's gonna
stay he enters that scene by God on the
coin right by grabbing the coin mm-hmm
and a lot of things happened in that
moment I didn't [ __ ] my pants you kept
it in but I look up and it and and I'm
doing this thing with this character
that I've created and no one has yet
said to me like great but I felt this
encouragement from the director because
he would always just pick you yeah yeah
yeah like he's not gonna go over the top
and be like oh that was wonderful you
know he just he likes it he's just gonna
keep
and but I was very insecure like it's
just
am I making an acid what and this really
me trying it out in his full form now
getting getting terrorized and I'm
crying kind of this character's crying
and making kind of weird noises are
coming out of me and in comes Batman and
he's like you really think that you know
you can learn something from him and and
he's and me and the two of them are such
serious focused actors and they're such
lovely guys but very serious and I hear
like you you think and they break and
they start laughing really they laugh
hard and I am crushed you oh of course
it's I'm looking at the ground like oh
my god I'm being that because there's
really our first full-time going for it
you know we'd rehearsed we block do you
think they literally cracked it you're
so I'm not and this hand is on my
shoulder all of a sudden and it's it's
the gloved it is the hand and it's even
got the little things on the side you
know and I'm like and he's got the
blackened out eyes and in the cowl and
he comes I mean he's like oh no I keep
got it that I was feeling that
insecurities like and he never really
broke his is his Bruce Wayne American
dialect except this one time he did it
and it was just to me and he was like oh
no no my I don't laugh at you who's like
a coin it just landed on my bed head and
they were dying laughing because when
Aaron had flipped the coin and Christian
was supposed to catch and they ended up
and he was like no you're wonderful and
then I'm looking at him going kid are
they getting this on camera every seller
this way you know it's so weird you guys
cuz you're this close looking at like
the utility belt and it's and it the
mastery of this stuff now I've gotten to
be around a number of things like this
when you're up close it looks amazing
but it looks so different than it it
looks the way it's meant to look in the
film course off in my person it's it's a
very different thing and there's a
science behind that that's fascinating
you know but it it was surreal what was
it like you get right away dude so you
wind up picking up a part in the movie
where you work with
Heath Ledger Christian Bale and Aaron
Eckhart like those are the three [ __ ]
stars with the exception gary oldman you
worked with [ __ ] everybody Gary
Oldman was in the scene no one was in
the scene so his trailer was next to
mine and every time I'd hear his trailer
opened for him to gotten and burn one I
had brought a pack so I could go out now
he was like freedom my god so for three
weeks you got to live in London on a
Warner Brothers dime go see plays and
then it ends with your waiting period
yeah ends with and now get to be a part
of a cinema classic and you're part of a
cinema classic do you not just do it as
in it when you think of that movie you
remember you when you think of that
scene you remember what you did in that
scene like that's why I was like there's
no way that those [ __ ] were laughing
at you
because they're both [ __ ] actor
actors man so if they saw you getting
like shitty and jittery and scared you
know they'd be like this shit's bring
the [ __ ] the whole game and they have
to up their [ __ ] game so that's why
were you telling stories like there's no
way [ __ ] it like I'm glad to hear that
because that is a memorable [ __ ]
performance saying afflict man like you
don't know what dude's name you're like
oh that [ __ ] guy so much so that when
you pop up a damn man I think I was with
Muse and we were both like also talk
that guy all right so on on dark night
anything else you remember what was the
demeanor of a Chris Nolan on set amazing
man yeah they're the thing that I I've
been really blessed man I've been able
in in my career to work with I think
just leaders in this field and I and I
really think that one and going back to
like the stage two there's this quality
that I found in masterful directors like
that it's it's a kind of confidence that
greatly transcends cockiness a
confidence that comes from knowing
exactly what you're trying to do or say
with the scene and having all the pieces
at play up here in this way that if he
had this like I don't know how to
describe it as a presence about him that
if he had we'd have much time to
interact but if he had said to me like
I feel like you should be on a tricycle
yeah I would have been like yes my
tricycle and and he had this um he had
this that this this air about in this
quality that was and it's been exceed in
different people in different ways for
him it was like a just a quiet kind of
confidence he kept his his monitor on
like it was like an iPad which at that
time was kind of right here so he was
always right off the action so when we
were shooting the scene in the back of
the animals I remember he had they had
cut a part out of the inland so he could
be right there and just feeding little
sigh coaching but the thing I'll always
love and remember the most was I was so
nervous and I'm sure being who he is and
so aware of all things that he probably
sensed that instantly because I think I
you know was like it's great to me
thanks so much for me today and started
joking with me in this way that was made
it almost felt like it was between us do
you know where he'd like companies anime
show me oh you you're getting all
thespian oh and it was like breaking
just getting me to loosen up and in this
way that so he's not like this serious
serious he's very serious very focused
but I get a really funny sense of humor
and I found that really surprising I
wasn't expecting that you don't look at
those movies and go like he seems like a
funny changed
he changed the landscape when it comes
to superhero films and I don't know if I
don't he did something achieved
something that was so true to the source
material and that's something that I can
be able to show my grandkids I hope
someday you know it's like you can look
at one of those movie to say oh yeah
that should have been oscar-nominated it
was Oscar nominated in one and Oscar
like and you don't blink for a second
because it's cinema yeah impressive god
beyond impressive dude but you fit in
you know what I'm saying you don't stick
out like sore thumb in the midst of this
like you [ __ ] blend into that world
man and that's a memorable is that your
first on-screen appearance yeah it's
[ __ ] memorable way to begin a career
in the choices that you made you know
acting as a job a choices all comes down
to choices and stuff
the choices you made made such an impact
man that [ __ ] that scene people
remember that [ __ ] scene Thanks and
it's not because of like the Batman
catches the coin and then they have this
back and forth the [ __ ] dude who's
terrified in the chair who they're
talking about or their conversation
about adds to the [ __ ] scene
heightens that scene so good on there's
a hell of a way to get called up from
the minors what a hell of a way to look
at all the times that I got [ __ ] back in
the day for blowing my lawn-mowing money
on comic books
I was so vindicated when I gave my
little studio apartment with long boxes
up to here just going like if that's the
only thing I ever get to do film wise
then I this was I just felt so like
there were so many people I wanted to
call and be like hey remember we used to
give you the kid for my comic this [ __ ]
panned out yeah I mean if the truck of
my intrepid I got a box full of slipper
from the Mandarin Oriental to stay at
man but for 21 days dude do you get to
get room service on that - I didn't get
word they gave me a per diem and I would
I'm really I was I was broke I mean I
wasn't flat broke but I I have been you
might make it more on your per day I
were making yes and then I go to that is
what I still I still disome Bera seem to
admit you're listening but I do this to
this today I travel a lot we live in we
don't live in hotels as much now as like
just like Airbnb Zoar rented apartment
and I like to take my per diem and go
buy groceries for the week and then go
out like one night a week maybe we'll go
cuz my family travels with me now you
know I so I was doing that then I'd be
like down to the thought this guy sit I
didn't know man I think I'd have like a
you know like like whatever the British
version is of the hungry man you know
version of the 7-eleven in Vienna to the
microwave that I could maybe like and
they they'd send it up on like a cart
they'd have microwave like silverware
like Dark Knight he must be somebody
he's got a lot of these beefy bloke
dinners so I guess treat him well use
our microwave that's [ __ ] phenomenal
man but that's just the Dark Knight
story we get to tell an ant-man story
next go to the wide on the very next
episode which David's gonna be on man
come back and we're gonna talk about
entering the Marvel Universe man in the
tiniest way possible teeny tiny that's
all we got time for right now the [ __ ]
what not amazing oh yeah thanks you guys
[ __ ] hell I've got a cure pal right
there this is a guy you want to get us
out of here next to Mankins [ __ ]
stories like this amazing [ __ ]
stories give it up for Dave dysfunction
that's 20 minutes or more between that's
what did it for you that's a big thanks
Dave dismal chan man come back next
episode and we're gonna talk more and
this time it'll be about ant-man and
[ __ ] Marvel and stuff like yes but
until then man thanks for hanging out
with us I've been Kevin Smith's mark
barnard and guess who that is stayed at
home you know dismal Jim yes thanks you
guys this has been don't worry you could
come back next week to stick around
dudes oh and ladies as well anybody come
back in one more episode in two days
same that time same fat chance marques
comm youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
hey Nance me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder